[Music]
before we start this video i want to
quickly shout out my mythology channel
mythology explained where i post all
kinds of extra content hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing the goblet of
fire bharti crouch jr madai moody and
the fabled marauders map more
specifically we're going to be
addressing a couple of lingering
questions that fans like yourselves
might have about the nature of the map
and how it goes about divulging
information question one is why didn't
mad i moody who was trapped in a magical
trunk show up on marauder's map and
question two is why wasn't the marauders
map able to identify barty crouch jr
surely simply spotting him on the map
would have made everyone's life a lot
easier right the map simply referred to
him as bartemus crouch also while we're
on the subject i should mention that
i've previously made a video on why
dumbledore wasn't able to figure out
that moody was a fake so if you're
wondering about that question check out
my old video which i'll link in the
description anyway let's dive into the
two questions above when the 94 school
year began like with any other year all
of the students gathered to the great
hall the beginning of term this was an
opportunity for dumbledore and any
professors to address the student body
at the beginning of the year announcing
anything pertaining to the upcoming
school year 1994 was the year that once
again a new defense against the dark
arts teacher took over famed death eater
captor alastair maddai moody from the
moment he first enters the great hall
students are transfixed by him a man
stood in the doorway leaning upon a long
staff shrouded in a black travelling
cloak every head in the great hall
swiveled towards the stranger suddenly
brightly illuminated by a fork of
lightning that flashed across the
ceiling he lowered his hood shook out a
long mane of grizzled dark gray hair
then began to walk up towards the
teacher's table a dull clunk echoed
through the hall on his every other step
the lightning had thrown the man's face
into sharp relief and it was a face
unlike harry had ever seen
it looked as though it had been carved
out of weathered wood by someone who had
only the vaguest idea of what human
faces were supposed to look like and was
none too skilled with a chisel every
inch of skin seemed to be scarred the
mouth looked like a diagonal gash and a
large chunk of his nose was missing but
it was the man's eyes that made him
frightening may i introduce our new
defense against the dark arts teacher
said dermodal brightly into the silence
professor moody alistair maddai moody
was a scottish pureblood wizard born
into the moody family a family known for
producing a plethora of amazingly
talented auras his reputation certainly
preceded him which is perhaps one of the
reasons that students and professors
alike gawked at him but what was
alistair madaimudi that was intended to
teach at the school that year and while
it certainly appeared to be moody it
really wasn't instead it was infamous
dark wizard and death eater barty crouch
jr you see before term began moody was
captured by bharti crouch jr who in 1982
had been given a life sentence to
azgaban however what many did not know
was that barty crouch jr had escaped
shortly after his sentencing which meant
that he was out and about for 13 years
something entirely unknown to the
general population
this allowed him to fly under the radar
and ultimately capture moody
after trapping moody in his own magical
bewitched trunk barty crutch jr went on
to impersonate moody for the school year
teaching defense against the dark arts
in his stead and quite well i might add
certainly better than umbrage in the
previous school year however we must
remember that harry came into the
possession of the marauders map a
magical map which due to the homunculus
charm is able to track the movements of
every person in the castle this begs the
question why on earth wasn't harry able
to see that moody was a fake while barty
crouch junior galavanted around the
castle the real moody was trapped in a
10-foot compartment inside of his own
magical trunk well the short answer is
that the map isn't entirely foolproof
for example one of the hidden
passageways in hogwarts isn't shown on
the map this is referenced in chapter 29
of the deathly hallows how long has this
been here ron asked as they set off it
isn't on the marauders map is it harry i
thought there were only seven passages
in and out of the school the map also
fails to disclose locations which are
hidden by magic places like the chamber
of secrets which would have certainly
sparked fred and george's curiosity if
it were visible and what map is able to
penetrate things like invisibility
cloaks which we know from chapter 17 of
the prisoner of azkaban the point is
even if you're wearing an invisibility
cloak you'll still show up on the
marauders map it certainly doesn't mean
that the map can't be tricked or that
the map's magic can't be overpowered
like with the room of requirement
hermione says the following in chapter
21 of the half-blood prince i think
it'll be part of the magic of the room
said hermione if you need it to be
unplottable it will be moody's bewitched
magical trunk was an advanced magical
item and moody was trapped within a
compartment hidden by the undetectable
extension charm in short the magic of
the trunk far outweighed the magic of
the marauders map but this still leaves
one very potent question why wasn't the
world's map able to identify barty
crouch jr it's a major plot point in the
goblet of fire that the marauders map
identifies bartemus crouch jr just as
martinez crouch which leads to all kinds
of confusion as party crutch jr is named
after his father and ministry official
party crouch senior so what's the deal
why isn't the map able to distinguish
between two people with the same name
if they were standing next to each other
would the map simply show bartenia's
crouch and martinez crouch well as it
turns out yes this is simply a flaw
within the workings of the map the
marauders map is undoubtedly a powerful
magical artifact but is it perfect no
the map appears to be designed to show
the full first and last name of every
person within range but because junior
is not an actual part of his name and
simply an affectation the same goes for
senior there is no way that the map
could reasonably distinguish between the
two men
when the map was being created it's
likely that this was just never
considered as it's highly unlikely the
two people with the same name would ever
be at hogwarts at the same time
furthermore the map was created for
mischief which makes these specific
distinctions like junior versus senior a
little bit irrelevant the map is
99.99999 percent effective but not 100
and it just so happens that the harry
potter plot highlights a time that it
wasn't to add to this even further
naming conventions among wizard kinds
are all over the place which makes the
likelihood of two people having the same
name infinitesimal for this reason it
simply wasn't considered however with
all that said martinez crouch appearing
on the map and not moody was still a bit
of a red flag
in fact bharti crutch jr himself
admitted that it nearly ruined
everything i used the map i had taken
from harry potter the map that had
almost ruined everything and the reason
he said this was because while moody was
absent on the map it certainly didn't
mean that harry wouldn't be able to see
martini's crouch right there where moody
was standing and that's it for this
video i hope that sufficiently answers
the two questions posed at the beginning
again if you want to know more about why
dumbledore wasn't able to identify barty
crouch jr then go and check out the
video linked in the description if you
enjoy the content please like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you